well you've no doubt heard the term
winter of discontent being thrown around
at the moment but are things really as
bad as the late 1970s and just how much
could it worse could it get in coming
months Britain's biggest unions unite
Unison the GMB rmt PCS CWU are taking
hundreds of thousands of workers out on
strike across Public Services the
transport Network and The Wider economy
it'll cause huge disruption and further
damage an economy struggling with
soaring inflation let's now talk to the
head of public services at the
organization that represents all trade
unions the TUC that's Kevin Rowan and he
joins me now um Mr own a very good to
talk to you today thanks for joining us
from up North there are people who will
not be able to travel after horrendous
periods being apart since covert over
the Christmas period that along with
many other disruptions to people's lives
over the next few days are the unions
holding the country to Ransom
well I think the unions are trying to
get a fair deal for their members and
you know uh right and you mentioned
right across the economy uh working
people are suffering the cost of living
crisis many of them haven't had a pay
rise for uh several years in in the
public services and most workers have
had below inflation pay Rises every year
under this government and you also heard
that the reason why these uh strengths
are not getting resolved and people you
know are able to call those uh little
strikes off is because the government
are effectively blocking the strengths
uh being uh Council so I think there is
certainly a a huge challenge here there
is certainly a massive impact on the
economy but the only way that we're
going to resolve these issues is if
people do get around the table and find
a solution and don't block and that the
government doesn't block Solutions when
they are on the table
the ambulance driver strikes is a one
that is causing a lot of fear for a lot
of people just talking to uh the unions
for the doctors who were saying who said
the chief believed people probably would
die over the coming weeks because of
what is happening are you worried that
there's going to be a shift in public
attitudes to to what is happening if
people start losing their loved ones
because of this
well I I think people are really really
worried about what's happening in the
Health Service already before the
strikes we see an ambulance and announce
his word in six eight hours before they
can drop their patients off I'll get the
patients into some emergency we're
seeing people waiting longer than they
have to in a a and in other parts of the
Health Service what we're seeing is uh
Public Services across the board that
are falling apart of the scenes so I
think the public are genuinely worried
about the level of public service and
it's a real I think Mark of Shame on
this government that those dedicated
professionals that we all rely on and we
all clapped through the pandemic field
so desperate that they have to take
industrial action just to get the
government to hear their experiences uh
both personal in terms of their wages
but also the services that they provide
that that's what people are going on
strike for in order to protect services
and ultimately give a decent service to
to those to those members of the public
and I think they get that I think that
they see where uh default lines here
they support uh the workforce and they
really want the government to get around
the table and find a solution at the
moment the government doesn't seem
prepared to do that yeah do you accept
though that what you're asking for is
unrealistic five percent on on top of
inflation is a huge sum the ifs thinks
it would probably cost every household
in the country about 640 pounds given
the cost of living crisis this just
isn't a bill that the the country as a
whole can afford
well I think you're right to focus on uh
affordability General and the the fact
is uh the government are making
political choices uh around taxation if
they were to to tax profit capital gains
tax and share dividends at the same rate
that they're taxing wages they would be
able to afford to give every public
service worker a fair pay rise but
they're choosing instead to effectively
stuff the pockets of the wealth for you
who get their income from profits and
shares and make and squeeze the purses
of the workers who are generating those
profits so these are political choices
the government could make different
choices that would allow them to pay
public sector workers properly what
they're choosing not to do so that in
all fairness the government though they
did increase taxes on some of those
higher salaries uh in the the recent
budget the ifs also uh as you know
independent and well-respected body they
say that when they look at a
remuneration because the the argument
that we hear from from unions like
yourselves that the public sector pay
isn't isn't keeping Pace with private
sector pay the ifs says when you look at
the Gap in total renumeration
accountable differences in both pay in
the private sector as well as
differences in employee characteristics
so things like pensions Etc the public
to private differential is about six
percent in other words total
remuneration for public sector workers
according to the ifs is an average six
percent higher than for those who are
privately employed so you know they
would say that and the government would
say that you're not taking into account
the other elements of working for the
public service that our benefits and and
that perhaps that is a bit a little bit
disingenuous you know when you're trying
to put your case towards the public
well the reality is that workers and
local government workers in health and
workers in in a civil service at the
lower end of those pay rates uh bumping
on just above the national minimum wage
just above in in pennies now we're not
talking about pounds or pennies above
the national minimum wage so there is an
absolute argument for improving pay in
the public sector but there are lots in
the private sector who are also on on
those salaries aren't there yeah
absolutely and we think all workers
should have a fair pay raise whether
they work in the private sector or in
the public sector and public sector
workers have seen their pensions
attacked year on year so people are
paying more now in their pension schemes
and enjoying a poorer pension when they
retire the fact is every year every
single year under this conservative
government public sector workers have
been made worse off and private sector
workers have been made much better off
either under this government they're
trashing the economy uh they're they're
they're taxing uh system favors the rich
and not the working class no these are
choices that the government are making
and public sector workers reserve a fair
pay raise Okay Kevin Rowan head of
public services at the TUC thank you
very much